à
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
voici le programme de cette après-midi
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement la séance est à suivre en
direct et en exclusivité dans un quart
d'heure parmi les thèmes abordés cet
après midi la participation de marlène
schiappa à une émission de cyril hanouna
c'est à suivre dans un quart d'heure
quelle suite pour la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur la sphère
benalla après l'audition hier de
l'ancien chargé de mission de l'elysée
les conclusions des parlementaires sont
particulièrement attendus ils promettent
des préconisations sévère pour éviter de
nouveaux dysfonctionnements parcours sub
saison 2 des milliers de lycéens peuvent
s'inscrire dès aujourd'hui sur cette
plateforme d'accès à l'université alors
que le défenseur des droits à demande
plus de transparence sur les critères de
sélection en publions les algorithmes
locaux comme le réclame et un sénateur
communiste
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission sur twitter le
hashtag à senna 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera tam tran
huy et alexandre pousseur en direct du
sénat le multiplex s'est tout de suite
c'est donc demain que prendra fin
officiellement la commission d' enquête
sur la sphère benalla après six mois de
travaux les sénateurs doivent maintenant
ont terminé leur rapport est publié
leurs conclu leurs conclusions au
lendemain d'une nouvelle convocation
d'alexandre benalla qui s'est retranché
derrière à l'instruction judiciaire dont
il fait l'objet pour esquiver les
questions des parlementaires sandra
cerqueira comme en septembre dernier
il arrive sous une nuée de caméras une
deuxième audition attendus notamment
pour faire la lumière sur l'utilisation
des passeports avant même d'être
interrogé alexandre benalla précise que
ces passeports ou été laissée à l'elysée
après son licenciement et qu'il les a
restitué en octobre dernier
il affirme ne pas avoir menti je tiens
juste à vous dire que j'ai constaté que
ces passeports et on m'a fait savoir que
ces passeports n'étaient pas désactivé
sinon je n'aurais pas voyagé avec ses
passeports alexandre au pénal a dit les
avoir utilisés 23 fois pour justifier de
son identité
mais la commission denquête n'apprendra
rien de plus l'ex chargé de mission à
l'elysée se retranche derrière
l'instruction judiciaire en cours
et prône son droit au silence faisant
ainsi monter la tension
à chaque nouvelle question vais réitérer
mon propos une troisième fois la justice
étant saisi des faits concernant les
passeports au sens large et les
passeports de service et les passeports
diplomatiques
s'intéressant également aux conditions
d'obtention de ces passeports ils n'ont
pas simplement conditions d'utilisation
et étant très respectueux des
institutions
je répondrai aux questions des
magistrats instructeurs monsieur bénard
permettez moi de vous dire vous avez une
conception singulière de ce que c'est
que le respect des institutions je dois
vous dire que le respect des
institutions
c'est aussi savoir que l'autorité
judiciaire n'a pas le droit de porter
d'appréciation sur une décision
administrative et par conséquent c'est
bien à nous de le faire
les pouvoirs d'enquêté de la commission
prenne fin ce jeudi
suivra un rapport avec des propositions
pour qu'une autre affaire benalla ne se
reproduise pas
comme le rappel régulier
les sénateurs et on prend la direction
de la salle des conférences où vous nous
attendait au tam traduit avec votre
premier invité aujourd'hui c'est le
sénateur socialiste des landes
éric kerrouche il a participé à cette
audition d'alexandre benalla wiki rouge
quel bilan faites-vous de l'audition
d'alexandre benalla une audition
largement frustrante ans alexandre bénin
a invoqué l' enquête judiciaire en cours
on touche aussi là un petit peu aux
limites de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire
on touche pas aux limites de la
commission d enquête parlementaire
on touche aux limites de ce qu'a bien
voulu nous dire alexandre bédat là et
c'est ça le problème parce que il nous
répète qu'il ne nous a pas menti
c'est peut-être vrai en tout cas moi ce
que je sais qu'il sait qu'il ne nous a
pas dit la vérité et donc il ya un vrai
problème dans l'ensemble de dans
l'ensemble de cette histoire qui s'est
encore confirmée avec l'audition je
disais qu'il y avait une limite de la
commission d enquête parlementaire parce
que finalement les sénateurs ont eu beau
répéter leurs questions ils n'ont pas
réussi à obtenir de réponse d'alexandre
bénard même en invoquant est bien le
fait que s'il ne répondait pas il y
avait sept mille cinq cents euros
damende deux ans d'emprisonnement
encourue
c'est le choix de la stratégie d'
alexandre bédat lancé le choix de la
stratégie faite par son avocat peu à mon
sens il y à il ya un vrai problème
il prend un vrai risque mais c'est lui
qui a choisi cette solution elle est
mauvaise parce qu'elle frustre
l'ensemble des observateurs bien entendu
la commission parlementaire mais plus
globalement l'ensemble des français qui
ont aussi droit avec cette commission
d'enquêté parlementaire
à la vérité l'art il est tout de même
sorti quelque chose c'est qu'alexandre
benalla continue à dire et bien que ces
passeports
il était resté dans son bureau qu'on les
lui a seulement restituer au mois
d'octobre
philippe a dit ce matin et bien soit il
ment soit il protège quelqu'un quel est
votre avis moi je pense que ce soit il
ment soit il ment et on a un vrai on a
un vrai souci
écoutez ou alors peut-être que nous
n'avons pas bien compris l'ensemble des
éléments qui nous ont été apportées mais
quand vous avez un ensemble de
contradictions et pas seulement chez
alexandre ménage chez la plupart des
protagonistes de l'histoire
ça veut dire qu'il ya un souci derrière
cette histoire est que je crois que il
faut pas être grand clerc pour se rendre
compte et tout le monde s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait
quand même quelque chose derrière cette
histoire beaucoup préconise avec des
préconisations justement sévère après
cette commission d' enquête sur tous les
dysfonctionnements qui les a pu avoir
l'elysée quel est votre avis je pense
qu'il faut aller au bout de cette
histoire pour une raison toute simple
parce que c'est pas l'élysée
institutions emmanuel macron qui est
visé c'est se dire que l'elysée c'est la
présidence de la république et c'est la
france et que cette image de la france
nous engage tous et que à l'étranger
l'utilisation de ces passeports
diplomatiques
elle n'est pas neutre et que donc bien
entendu il faut avoir la plus grande
sévérité dans les suites de cette
affaire parce que encore une fois elle
engage notre image collective et c'est
ça qui ne faut pas gâcher
eh bien merci beaucoup eric héraud java
répondu à mes questions merci merci à
vous au thème pour cette première
réaction pierre ouzeau liesse va-t-il
avoir enfin gain de cause le sénateur
communiste réclament depuis un an avec
d'autres élus et des syndicats étudiants
la publication des algorithmes locaux
mises en place par chaque université est
jugée discriminant par les lycéens de
banlieue
le défenseur des droits vient d'appuyer
sa demande la balle est désormais dans
le camp du gouvernement les explications
de sagna de sheer les universités
utilisent bien des algorithmes locaux
pour sélectionner les candidats des
algorithmes dont on ne connaît pas les
critères dénonce le défenseur des droits
saisis entre autres par des syndicats
étudiants et des élus jacques toubon a
rendu sa décision hier
parmi ces recommandations prendre les
mesures nécessaires afin de rendre
publiques toutes les informations
relatives aux traitements y compris
algorithmique afin d'assurer la
transparence de la procédure
le défenseur des droits donne donc
raison aux opposants un parcours sup
parmi eux le sénateur pierre ouzou
liesse dénonce depuis un an ses
algorithmes locaux dont le gouvernement
nier l'existence
maintenant il ya besoin de restaurer la
confiance la confiance des candidats des
candidates par rapport à parcours super
pied aussi la confiance
du ministre et de son gouvernement par
rapport à la représentation nationale
il n'est pas normal que pendant un an on
nous a fermé que ses algorithmes
n'existait pas alors que maintenant on a
appris que y en avait eu environ dans
25% des filières autre inquiétude
partagée par le défenseur des droits
la discrimination des bacheliers en
fonction de leur lycée d'origine
jacques toubon recommande tout
simplement d'interdire ce critère en
anonymisant les dossiers des candidats
il est pourtant soutenu par laurent
wauquiez président des républicains et
pourtant françois xavier bellamy peine à
convaincre
c'est lui qui devrait être choisi comme
chef de file dlr pour les élections
européennes est loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein de son propre parti
comme a pu le constater ce matin au
groupe les républicains du sénat à notre
journaliste jean barbier il est le grand
favori pour prendre la tête de liste des
républicains aux élections européennes
françois xavier bellamy 33 ans
philosophe aurait été choisi par laurent
wauquiez pour mener son camp à cette
élection est le patron du groupe au
sénat est sur la même longueur d'onde
je trouve que françois xavier bellamy
serait en tête de liste pour deux
raisons la première c'est un renouvelle
le renouvellement il est jeune et
surtout c'est les convictions c'est un
refondations à partir et dvg au problème
pour certains ses positions sur les
sujets de société et lui à versailles
opposé personnellement ali léger et très
en vue lors de manifestations de la
manif pour tous il incarne une droite
conservatrice même s'il ne sera pas seul
sur la liste
c'est un jeune brillant qui défendra ses
idées sur les aspects peut-être un peu
plus conservateur ce plan des moeurs de
la vision de la famille mais je pense
que tout cas moi personnellement ça me
convient tout à fait et sur d'autres
sujets et bien nous verrons bien il y
aura d'autres personnes sur la liste
pour défendre et il est de rassembler un
maximum de france est possible se tenir
mais sa candidature provoque des débats
importants dans le parti et la droite
plus sociale met en garde attention à ne
pas transformer les républicains en un
petit parti conservateur il faut un
candidat le plus consensuel possible qui
incarne bien une europe qui protège et
qui qui est des positions
qu'ils aillent dans ce sens et qui est
si possible une connaissance assez forte
des problèmes européens voilà mon avis
une position partagée par gérard larcher
qui a publiquement fait part de ses
réticences mais difficile de trouver des
candidats expérimentés pour lui faire
face
la commission d'investiture prévue mardi
prochain risque d'être animée malgré le
peu de suspense sur cette désignation de
pays et faire avancer l'europe y l'on a
signé un nouveau traité 1 c'était ce
matin en allemagne avec ce la chapelle
un traité qui provoque un tollé parmi
les nationalistes des deux pays
le président français a accusé justement
cette dernier de répandre des mensonges
dangereux à ce sujet on écoute le chef
de l'état ceux qui caricaturent ou
répandre le mensonge font mal à notre
histoire et à nos peuples qu'ils
prétendent défendre
en voulant faire bégayer nos histoires
et le président de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat le
sénateur
elle est raison bizet était justement à
aix la chapelle il vient tout juste de
rentrer il est à vos côtés at and tran
huy oui jean bizet et bien votre
commentaire sur ce que vient de dire eh
bien le président de la république
emmanuel macron qui a parlé des
mensonges de caricatures autour de ce
traité d'aix-la-chapelle et fait bien
sûr référence aux propos dénonciation de
marine le pen et nicolas dupont aignan
qui disent notamment que le traité va
conduire à vendre l'alsace et la
lorraine à l'allemagne s'est
littéralement scandaleux alors que je
dirais cet événement est assez
extraordinaire c'était un jour
historique qui permet de relancer un
petit peu le couple franco allemand et
qui permet de rappeler au travers des
propos et de madame merkel et du
président macron l'importance je dirais
d'une cohésion entre l'allemagne et la
france
l'importance également du dossier de la
défense et l'importance également des
convergences moi je crois que il était
nécessaire 56 ans après de rappeler je
dirais pour le
need et la cohésion des vingt-sept le
rôle du couple franco-allemand important
de renforcer ce couple alors même que
l'europe est menacée
on le voit notamment avec avec ce break
site qui est toujours plus d'actualité
l'europe est menacée certes mais l
europe avance même si elle avance
doucement elle avance avec beaucoup de
sérieux et regarder en italie on
parvient malgré tout à faire rentrer le
budget italia dans les clous dans les
pays d'europe de l'est
l'état de droit tout doucement s'impose
même au delà de l'arctique du
déclenchement de l'article 7
et puis il nous reste bien évidemment le
break site mais cela si vous voulez
c'est la particularité du monde anglo
saxon qui découvre enfin qui après avoir
déclenché de façon assez rationnel je
dirais le référendum de juin 2016
s'aperçoit que le dossier irlandais d'un
dossier insoluble donc nos amis anglais
ont le choix entre deux choses désormais
ou bien respecter le choix de leurs
ressortissants à qui on a menti et c'est
la ruine de l'économie et je dirais
britannique et je dirais de forts
désagréments sur l'ensemble je dirais de
l'union européenne ou bien et bien
sortir par le haut tout cela et puis
déclencher un nouveau référendum
un mot sur françois xavier bellamy
serait-il pour vous une bonne tête de
liste pour l'est républicain aux
prochaines élections européennes
est-ce que son opposition personnelle à
alléger pour vous un obstacle pour
représenter les républicains écoutez je
ne connais pas françois-xavier bellamy
je crois ne pas être le seul
mais au delà je dirais de la tête de
liste pour moi c'est le casting de toute
la liste qu'on puisse enfin envoyé à
l'europe des hommes ou des femmes qui
sont compétents en la matière qui ne
soient pas des recalés du suffrage
universel ou des apparatchiks
ce n'est pas son cas la france à
françois-xavier bellamy site un signe
peut-être de renouvellement commence en
nous en génération à nouveau oui mais je
vous ai dit le casting de l'ensemble de
la liste de façon à envoyer des hommes
et des femmes qui défendent
je dirais les intérêts de l'europe comme
ça faire je dirais nos voisins allemands
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence
si beaucoup jean bizet d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous tous pour
cette nouvelle réaction dans le reste de
l'actualité le groupe chinois huawei a
un coût et inquiète à les pays
occidentaux au point que la france
cherche d'ailleurs des pistes pour que
le constructeur reste sous contrôle
c'est la première se faire par voie
d'amendement dans la loi pacte elle
arrive au sénat mardi prochain jonathan
du prez d'abord prudente
puis hésitante la france semble
s'inquiéter du cac huawei selon les
échos bercy songerait à un amendement
dans le projet de loi pacte actuellement
examiné au sénat amendement qui viserait
à limiter le développement de la marque
en france notamment sur le réseau 5 g si
on se coupe de la possibilité de
s'approvisionner chez les chinois ne
reste plus que les américains aient
malheureusement et c'est ça le gros
problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
d'opérateur pour ces matériels en europe
je crois que cela méritera un débat si
c'est tellement marrer parce qu'il faut
bien penser à la presse
l'une des mesures envisagées par le
gouvernement serait d'étendre les
prérogatives de l'anssi l' agence de
sécurité des systèmes d'information l'
agence pourrait obtenir un droit de
regard rétroactif sur les produits
huawei déjà vendu en france
pour jean marie bockel sénateur
spécialiste des questions de
cybersécurité la marque chinoise est
déjà très encadrées restrictions sur
l'interdiction de développer des
routeurs le coeur de réseau qui sont les
véritables le possibilité de cheval de
troie restrictions sur la part de marché
moins de 50% en tout état de cause pas
quelque chose c'est de savoir par
rapport à de nouvelles conditionnalités
ce qui est utile acceptable et ce qui
reviendrait à une interdiction
la france n'est pas dans l'état d'esprit
de faire du protectionnisme déguisé sur
le sujet japon australie etats unis ces
pays soupçonnent huawei d'espionnage au
service de pékin
cette méfiance n'a pour le moment été
étayées d'aucune preuve voilà et on bat
ensuite à retrouver alexandre poussard
alors que les questions d'actualité vont
débuter dit
et trente secondes alexandre et oui les
filles nées ces questions actualité vont
porter notamment sur le grand débat
national et sur la stratégie médiatique
du gouvernement avec la polémique du
jour la participation de marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état à un débat
avec cyril hanouna sur la chaîne ces
huit là secrétaire d'état animera ce
débat avec plusieurs citoyens français
et certains critiques
un mélange des genres vous allez voir la
défense de la secrétaire d'état tout de
suite les questions d'actualité
merci monsieur le président l'agencé
régionale de santé des os de france
vient d'acter la fermeture de la
maternité de creil dans l'oise et son
transfert à senlis cette décision se
fait contre l'avis des élus locaux
notamment le maire de creil jean claude
villemain le maire de montataire ancien
sénateur mon ami et camarade jean pierre
bosino elle se fait contre l'avis des
usagers des syndicalistes des personnels
de santé il faut pas être jaloux
il y a un an j'étais déjà à leurs côtés
pour manifester contre cette menace de
fermeture à l'appel du comité de défense
très actif
loïc pen chef de service des urgences a
démissionné pour protester contre cette
fermeture peu importe vous passer en
force et tant pis pour les 1500
accouchements réalisés par en au sein de
cette maternité de niveau 3 d'autres
maternités sont touchés comme celle du
bernay dans l'eure du blanc dans l'indre
ou encore de guingamp dans les côtes
d'armor une véritable catastrophe
sanitaire qui se fait au détriment de
l'intérêt des femmes d'autant plus à
l'heure de l'aggravation des déserts
médicaux
madame la ministre les hôpitaux publics
les ehpad secteur psychiatrique qui
manifestent aujourd'hui même sont en
grande souffrance pour répondre aux
mouvements des blouses blanches vous
opposez votre projet de loi pour la
transformation de notre système de santé
qui comprend 23 articles dont 14 par
ordonnance faut-il le rappeler
pensez vous vraiment qu'un moyen
constant ce projet peut améliorer
l'accès aux soins la qualité de la prise
en charge sur tout le territoire et les
conditions de travail des personnels
pour vous répondre la parole éternelle
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame agnès buzyn vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice laurence cohen
parmi les nombreuses affirmations que
vous avez fait dont le très nombreux
sont fausses
il y en a une que je ne peux pas laisser
passer une qui est que tout cela se fait
au détriment des femmes aujourd'hui un
certain nouveau de maternité en france
vous le savez fonctionne dans des
situations dégradées de sécurité gelée
affirmé je le réaffirme devant vous tous
aucune décision de fermetures de
maternité ou de services de proximité
aujourd'hui en france n'est prise sur
des raisons financières la totalité de
mes décision est fondée sur des
questions de sécurité liées à notamment
un défaut de remplissage des listes de
garde dans un certain nombre de
maternités avec parfois des maternités
qui fonctionne sans pédiatre sans
anesthésistes avaient que pour certaines
maternités des plateaux techniques qui
ne sont plus en capacité d'assurer la
sécurité des parturientes
et donc c'est centre de mater maternité
sont actuellement transformé en centre
de périnatalité qui au contraire
améliore la qualité du suivi des femmes
font de la prévention font de
l'accompagnement à l'accouchement de la
sophrologie des suivis psychologiques
font de l'éducation thérapeutique
reçoivent les femmes après leur
accouchement pour tisser le mien le lien
mère enfant
il n'y a donc pas de fermetures de
maternités amédée transformation en
centres de périnatalogie et seul l'acte
d'accouchement et transférer la seule
chose qui motive aujourd'hui les
décisions qui sont prises par les
agences régionales de santé sont des
décisions de sécurité sanitaire et pour
parler de la maternité de creil qui vous
tient à coeur madame la sénatrice vous
le savez la décision était prise par les
équipes médicales dans le cadre la rue
de la restructuration de ces deux
établissements avant que je n'arrive au
gouvernement c'était une décision qui
avait été prise en 2017
et donc c'est un processus de
restructuration de ces deux hôpitaux qui
se poursuit avec l'aval des
professionnels de santé
je vous remercie
merci madame cohen je m'inscris
totalement en faux vous propos madame la
mini c'est une méconnaissance de la
population du bassin de creil 40 % de
personnes ne possèdent pas de véhicule
donc c'est sûr que ça va être beaucoup
plus sécure d'accoucher dans une voiture
ou dans un camion de pompiers donc il
faut arrêter de faire des économies sur
la gorge des hôpitaux 2 milliards 2
milliards d'économies depuis votre
élection depuis deux ans ça suffit les
problèmes de santé sont vitaux pour les
françaises et les français
malheureusement ça n'appartient pas au
grand débat national c'est un scandale
la parole est à notre collègue martial
bourquin
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
mon cher collègue vous avez la parole
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre nous avons appris
que la commission européenne pourrait
remettre en cause l'accord fut de fusion
conclu entre siemens et alstom
deux choix s'offrent à nous aujourd'hui
à la france soit les groupes accepte de
nouvelles cessions d'actifs
synonymes de suppressions de production
et d'emplois et de sites industriels
peut-être choix ce sera un refus de la
commission européenne nous partageons
comme vous le dogmatisme de la
commission sur la question de la
concurrence qui empêche l'émergence de
champions européens
cependant nous l'avons dit et répété
l'accord siemens alstom était un mauvais
accord qui est plus une absorption
d'alstom par siemens qu'une véritable
fusion entre égaux
monsieur le ministre nous vous demandons
de refuser toute nouvelle cession
d'actifs qui serait synonyme de
démantèlement d'alstom et en cas de
refus de l'europe
vous devez mettre sur pied une stratégie
nationale
alstom s'est désendetté a gagné de
nombreux marchés à travers le monde il
va être urgent de mettre en place un
pacte d'actionnaires en vue d'une
véritable stratégie industrielle
thales par exemple entreprise pionnière
dans la signalisation pourraient
participer à ce pacte d'actionnaires il
est aussi nécessaire que la caisse de
dépôt et de consignation où la banque
publique d'investissement choix associer
un pacte d'actionnaires pour protéger
alstom contre d'éventuels prédateurs
financiers
monsieur le ministre avez vous la
volonté de défendre ce fleuron
industriel pour vous répondre la parole
et au ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur bruno le maire vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bourquin
j'ai parfois l'impression que la
commission européenne les responsables
européens ne vivent pas dans le même
monde que le nôtre et non pas vu et
n'ont pas vu
et n'ont pas vu que depuis quinze ans un
champion chinois de l'industrie
ferroviaire avait émergé il y à 26 mille
kilomètres de lignes à grande vitesse et
très grande vitesse en chine qui est un
marché captif pour les chinois dans neuf
pays en europe sert rc fait 200 à 220
trains à grande vitesse ou à très grande
vitesse
chaque année alstom et siemens à eux
deux ils en font 35 crc c'est le double
du chiffre d'affaires d'alstom et de
siemens réunit donc je considère qu'il
est temps que nous adaptions les règles
de la concurrence européenne à la
réalité de l'industrie mondiale du 21e
siècle et il est temps que nous
arrêtions d'appliquer en 2019 des règles
de la concurrence européenne qui n'ont
pas été modifiés depuis 15 ans depuis
l'europe doit changer pour mieux
protéger notre industrie et défendre
notre industrie nationale et européenne
alstom et siemens vous avez parfaitement
raison monsieur bourquin ont fait des
concessions
ils ont fait du team concessions pour
répondre aux demandes de la commission
européenne alstom et siemens ne feront
pas de concessions supplémentaires qui
pourraient fragiliser ces deux groupes
c'est maintenant à la commission
européenne de prendre ses
responsabilités mais soyez en sûr nous
prendrons les nôtres j'estime que si
jamais la commission européenne devait
rendre une décision négative sur la
création d'un champion industriel
européen d'un géant du ferroviaire pour
résister à la concurrence chinoise et la
concurrence d'autres grandes nations du
monde
elle ferait une erreur économique est
une faute politique
[Applaudissements]
monsieur burqa
quelques secondes pénis 8500 personnes
en france sur douze sites 4500
fournisseurs 27 mille emplois ça vaut la
peine de défendre ce fleuron industriel
merci la parole est à notre collègue à
la marque pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires
je voudrais puisqu'elle concerne les
zones de revitalisation rurale associer
mon ami et collègue de jean claude luche
cette question à l'aveyron les
exonérations sociales et fiscales sont
de l'ordre de 6 millions 5 par an ceci
pour l'année 2010 est ce dispositif qui
finalement me paraît intéressant pour
nos territoires ruraux a été évalué par
deux collègues députés à l'assemblée
nationale ses deux collègues en blanc de
l'aviron et véronique louwagie de l'orne
après des auditions on ne doit pas
auditionner les mêmes gens on déclaré à
la conclusion que les dispositifs de
zones de revitalisation rurale ne
servait pas à grand chose et elle ont
préconisé qu'il faudrait désormais les
mettre à la mène des préfets mais non
pas pour l'objet pour lequel elles sont
faits aujourd'hui mais pour augmenter la
detr en direction des mères madame le
ministre quel sort et quelle suite
allez-vous donner à ce rapport à ce
rapport pour vous répondre la parole est
à la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales madame
jacqueline gourault vous avez la parole
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur
comme vous le savez est parfaitement les
parlementaires sont libres de faire des
rapports et décrire ce qu'ils veulent
dans leur rapport
les zones de revitalisation rurale
constitue vous savez un dispositif
essentiel pour le soutien aux
territoires ruraux et le gouvernement y
est très attaché fondée sur le
croisement de deux critères simultanée
la densité de population et la richesse
des habitants ce dispositif contribue
activement à la création d'emplois dans
ces territoires vous souvenez que de la
réforme de 2015 a permis de maintenir le
nombre global de communes classées à
14000 cette réforme a fait des gagnants
qui entrent dans le dispositif et des
perdants qui sortent du thil dispositif
l écoute de ses critiques qui s'étaient
élevées des craintes exprimées par les
communes sortante
après cette réforme ou de 2015 le
gouvernement a prévu dans la loi de
finances pour 2010 8 que les communes
sortante puissent continuer à bénéficier
des effets du classement en zrr
cette décision du gouvernement permet
ainsi et jusqu'en 2020 peu près de 18000
commune de doivent bénéficier du
dispositif de zone rrr soit près de la
moitié des communes françaises donc nous
avons été dans un sens d'élargissement
monsieur le sénateur dans la perspective
de l'échéance de 2020 le gouvernement
conduit actuellement des travaux de
réflexion il ya eu des projets des
parlementaires 20 des travaux
parlementaires des députés calmette et
vigier blanc et lova j qui sont sortis à
ce stade des réflexions
il apparaît que le classement ederer sur
des critères communaux et non à
l'échelle des opci conduirait à annie et
vêtements important du dispositif qui ne
ferait que exacerber les concurrence
territoriale soit un effet opposé à
celui recherché
toutes les options sont donc sur la
table monsieur le
sénateurs et les gouvernements les
alizés tu dis pardon avec la plus grande
attention afin d'assurer à ce dispositif
le maximum de son efficacité au profit
des territoires ruraux et faut qu'au
moment où nous voulons faire un agenda
rural soyez assurés de nadal pour
vraiment trop cher lab le ministre
pourquoi changer quelque chose qui
marche je suis tellement pas mal du tout
ce matin j'ai interrogé plusieurs
établissements pour handicapés maison
familiale rurale ehpad et ses atouts
sont très contentes du système
d'autre part je peux vous assurer que
par exemple en aveyron où certaines
communes ont une densité de cinq à six
habitants au kilomètre carré
on a été très contente de pouvoir faire
venir des médecins dont on ne sait pas
le critère essentiel que de venir et
être exonérés de haut niveau fiscal
pendant quelques années mais c'est un
critère supplémentaire qui nous permet
de renforcer l'attractivité
alors je vous en conjure nous nous
allons je pense essayer de faire à notre
tour
les évaluations sur le territoire mais
ce système ne marche pas mal
bien au contraire nous en sommes heureux
et je souhaite qu'ils perdurent pour nos
territoires ruraux
merci la parole est à françois noël
buffet pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole de leurs collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur le gouvernement le 15
janvier dernier vient de donner des
statistiques 2018 de la politique
migratoire
tous les chiffres sans exception sont en
hausse sauf un celui du traitement de
l'immigration irrégulière l'immigration
régulière est à plus deux cent cinquante
cinq mille personnes pour 2018
la demande d'asile est en augmentation
de 22% en 2010 8 par rapport à 2010 7
par rapport à 2017 et le taux de renvoi
dans les pays d'origine des gens en
situation irrégulière est à peu elle a
ses petits assez faible moins de 10% en
tous les cas pour cette année 2010 8
le gouvernement nous dit que tout va
bien puisque pour le budget 2010 9 ne
prévoit pas d'augmentation particulière
singulièrement pour le traitement de
l'asile mais également pour le
traitement de l'immigration irrégulière
le président de la république vient de
dire qu' il souhaitait mettre dans le
débat l'immigration et singulièrement
reprendre une idée du sénat qui est
celle des quotas annuels que nous
défendrons depuis des années dans cet
hémicycle machine mise l'intérieur
comment comptez vous aborder cette année
2010 9 qui s'annonce en matière de
politique migratoire bien au delà de
toutes vos espérances qui plaide pour la
stabilité même sans doute pour tout le
contraire merci pour vos réponses
la parole et secrétaire d'état auprès du
matériel monsieur laurent le monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
m'interrogez sur les statistiques
annuelles en matière d'immigration
publie effectivement récemment par le
ministère de l'intérieur comme vous
l'avez dit en 2018 nous constatons
effectivement une hausse de 21 6% des
demandes enregistrées par l'ofpra et
cette hausse est notamment due aux flux
ce qu'on appelle les flux secondaire
je tiens à souligner pour répondre à
votre question que notre politique
d'immigration d'accueil est juste et
réaliste
nous nous donnons les moyens de
l'accueil dans des délais raisonnables
c'est une volonté forte de la loi
adoptée en septembre 2018 mais nous
procédons aussi à des mesures
d'éloignement
comme le prévoit
une loi de septembre 2018 la loi asile
et immigration à ce titre les
éloignement forcé sont en hausse
significative et se sont d'ailleurs là
c'est la progression en chiffre la plus
haute depuis le début de cette décennie
ces chiffres témoignent de l'efficacité
de notre politique contre l'immigration
irrégulière
ils ne sont pas le fruit du hasard il
résulte bien sûr de la loi que je viens
de rappeler du 10 septembre 2018 mais
aussi de nos dispositifs de contrôle aux
frontières qui ont été significativement
renforcée sur la frontière franco
italienne sur la franc chrtr frontière
franco espagnole
je me suis rendu moi même le
gouvernement a nommé un coordonnateur en
charge de renforcer ses contrôles qui
sont maintenant tout à fait effectif
quant au budget de l'année 2019 ce
budget donne au gouvernement les moyens
de conduire une politique tout à fait
équilibrée que je rappelle de garantir
le droit d'asile mais aussi de procéder
à une pensée à des mesures d'éloignement
et ce budget asile immigration il est en
augmentation de près de 7% en 2019 il
nous faut cependant reconnaître et
écouter l'inquiétude de nos concitoyens
une inquiétude qui s'est manifesté avec
une virulence particulière à propos du
pacte de marrakech
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le sénateur que le gouvernement a choisi
de que les problématiques pardon de
l'immigration soit abordée dans le grand
débat qui va se tenir dans les semaines
qui viennent
et ces échanges se tiendront notamment
au regard donc de là la thématique sur
le débat démocratique et la citoyenneté
je vous remercie monsieur buffet et
monsieur le ministre je ne partage pas
votre optimisme depuis de nombreuses
années dans cette maison nous défendons
une autre politique migratoire
la première c'est cette d'accueillir -
mais d'accueillir mieux et beaucoup
mieux que ce qui fait jusqu'à maintenant
la seconde c'est effectivement de
traiter l'asile dans de bons délais mais
de traiter surtout les déboutés du droit
d'asile
or aujourd'hui deux événements vont en
faire jour l'augmentation de la demande
d'asile sera réel en 2019 elle sera même
plus importante peut-être que cette
année le traitement l'immigration
irrégulière
en réalité vous avez beaucoup plus
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
national qui ont été prononcées donc le
niveau d'exécution reste faible quoi que
vous en disiez et que pour l'instant
nous allons proposer des solutions nous
au sénat je souhaite que prétend la
république hellénique d'exécutif
prennent en compte ces propositions
singulièrement sur la notion de quotas
et de débat nous falloir mais également
sur la notion de visa en contrepartie de
laisser passer consulaire accordés par
les pays sources merci
la parole est à notre collègue pierre
médevielle pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole mais ce qui est
évident ma question s'adresse au
ministre les cultures mais chez le
ministre mardi 15 janvier le tribunal
administratif de lyon a annulé
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché du
round up 360 pro la juridiction appuyé
sa décision sur le fait que l'on cesse
aurait comme une appréciation regard du
principe de précaution en autorisant le
produit en mars 2010 m la communauté
scientifique dans sa majorité le monde
agricole et les industriels ne
comprennent absolument pas ce type de
décision totalement arbitraire à la
demande de l'opex avec un collègue
pierre ouzoulias nous allons remettre
prochainement un rapport analysant les
dysfonctionnements possibles et la crise
de confiance naissante vis-à-vis de nos
agences d expertise notre travail mettra
en valeur le souci d'harmonisation et de
cohérence dans nos politiques
d'évaluation ne pensez vous pas monsieur
le ministre que ce type de décision
discrédite totalement le travail
remarquable de l'ansès dont
l'indépendance et les compétences ne
sont plus à prouver encore les tribunaux
administratifs sont ils compétents pour
traiter ce genre de dossier ne
craignez-vous pas une surenchère dans le
suppression des autorisations de mise
sur le marché au nom du principe de
précaution d'alimentation monsieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pierre médevielle la décision
du tribunal administratif de lyon 2,8 en
mai dernier n'a pas vocation à être
commentée en tout cas je n'ai pas à le
faire le gouvernement n'a pas à le faire
je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposer
décision de justice et décisions
scientifiques principe de précaution et
rationalité ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'en tout état de cause de
gouvernement tout entier soul est du
premier ministre est tout entier
mobilisé pour faire à la fois multi
l'agriculture et pour donner aux
agricultures les moyens de participer à
cette transition agro écologique est
absolument indispensable
nous avons interdit le chef de l'état
demandé l'interdiction en france du
glyphosate avant le 1er janvier 2021
alors qu en europe ça pourrait être
beaucoup plus longtemps avec madame
busan
ceux du riz j nous avons demandé à
l'ansés de revoir toutes les mises en
marché possible pour savoir ce qu'il en
est réellement
je ne crois pas qu'il faille opposer les
uns et les autres d'ores et déjà le
round up est interdite depuis le 1er
janvier
pour les particuliers il est interdit
depuis il sera interdit le 1er février
pour toute dispersion avant les récoltes
afin de protéger d'éventuels risques et
le principe de précaution aujourd'hui je
pense vraiment qu'il ne faut pas opposer
le principe de précaution et l'aspect
scientifique
les scientifiques doivent permettre à
leur travail on sait très bien que la
demande de nos concitoyens la demande
société que le principe de précaution
liées à la santé de nos concitoyens est
là et mon rôle est le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de protéger nos
constitué de protéger les français et en
même temps de donner les moyens à
l'agriculture de muter certes mais de se
développer de continuer à être
compétitives de continuer à gagner des
parts de marchés à l'extérieur de
continuer à se développer en termes
locales et de circuits courts est comme
l'a très bien dit le président de la
république et c'est la position du
gouvernement
aucune filière aucun paysan ne sera
laissée sans solution je vous remercie
monsieur gabriel monsieur le ministre
protéger la population oui mais protéger
aussi des agriculteurs
notre culture de redevenir un des fers
de lance de notre économie
or elle occupe aujourd'hui un cinquième
rang totalement digne de son potentiel
s'abriter derrière le principe de
précaution c'est l'obscurantisme
scientifique
c'est le record que vivement sur soi
même comment peut-on ambitionner d'avoir
une agriculture productive compétitive
au niveau européen et mondial et lui
faire subir les états d'âme de juge
archaïque incompétent ainsi que les faux
billets les élucubrations des tous les
prédicateurs de la lampe à huile
donc il va falloir faire des choix
il faut retrouver l'ambition feu
retrouver l'audace faire confiance à nos
chercheurs à nos experts en urgence et
nous retrouverons les chemins du progrès
et de la sécurité vive la république
vive l'agriculture et vive la science
archi la parole et à notre collègue
dominique théophile pour le groupe de la
république en mars
monsieur le président les chiens
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités
madame la ministre huit maisons de
naissance ont été ouvertes à la suite de
la loi du 6 décembre 2013 autorisant
leur expérimentation et du décret paru
en 2015 précisant les conditions deux
ans plus tard ces maisons offrent un
accompagnement des naissances plus
personnalisée plus naturel permettant
aux parents d'être suivie depuis le
début de la grossesse jusqu'à la
surveillance post natale par les mêmes
sage femme dans un cadre intime a fait
de partager leurs observations ces
structures sont entrés en réseau et en
échanger leurs expériences
elles ont ainsi conclu collectivement
que le niveau de satisfaction des
parents et des sages femmes y
travaillent en était élevé et ont
constaté une demande plus importante que
prévu malgré ses conclusions positives
les maisons de naissance connaissent
certaines difficultés notamment liées à
un manque de visibilité sur les suites
qui seront données à leurs
expérimentations qui doit prendre fin
à fin novembre 2020 comme prévu par les
textes législatives les rapports
d'évaluation étaient adressées par
toutes les maisons de naissance au 31
mars 2010 est aux ars et au ministère de
la santé après deux ans d'exercice
toutefois ces rapports n'ont pas encore
été exploitées et cela laisse les
sages-femmes et les parents dans
l'expectative
afin d'éviter une rupture dans la prise
en charge des parents le moment venu et
de laisser aux sages-femmes le temps de
se réorienter professionnellement cas
d'arrêt de l'expérimentation
il s'agirait d' étudier rapidement ces
évaluations de ce fait madame la
ministre
mais question seront les suivantes
l'exploitation de ces rapports
d'évaluation aura-t-elle lieu sous peu
et puis compte tenu de son succès sans
attendre la fin de l'expérimentation le
dispositif des maisons de naissance ne
pourrait-il pas être élargi à l'ensemble
des territoires et mis en place de
manière pérenne à l'occasion du projet
de loi de santé prévue pour 2019
solidarité de santé madame usa vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur dominique théophile
effectivement neuf maisons de santé ont
été autorisés en novembre 2015 dont deux
en guadeloupe et à la réunion
sur la base de cette expérimentation
prévue de par la loi du 6 décembre 2013
et sur la base d'un cahier des charges
proposé par la haute autorité de santé
ces maisons de naissance sont des
structures autonomes qui sont dirigés
par des sages femmes ayant pour mission
d'accueillir les femmes enceintes du
début de leur grossesse jusqu'à leur
accouchement
dès lors qu'il n'ya aucun facteur de
risque connu
ces maisons de naissance attenantes
d'une maternité partenaires en cas de
nécessité transfert des mère ou de
l'enfant en cas d'urgence après deux ans
de fonctionnement effectif on constate
que l'activité globale des maisons de
naissance est resté modeste sur le plan
quantitatif
chaque structure a assuré entre 35 et
125 naissance en cumul depuis 2015 sur
le plan qualitatif il n'a pas été
signalée auprès des agences régionales
de santé d'événements indésirables
graves notamment grâce à l'efficacité
des procédures d'orientation des femmes
enceintes des parturientes vers les
maternités attenante en cas de
complications ou de facteurs de risque
au moment de la grossesse
par ailleurs et vous avez raison les
données remontées par des rapports
d'évaluation font état d'une bonne
satisfaction des parturientes et des
équipes aujourd'hui la réflexion est
donc en cours sur l'avenir de ces
maisons de naissance nous l'intégrons
cette réflexion à la réforme des
autorisations d activités de soins
c'est une réforme qui a été lancée en
2018 et notamment nous avons des travaux
particuliers sur les autorisations
relatifs à la périnatalité qui ont
débuté en juillet
2018 donc les travaux sont en cours
monsieur le sénateur se vendre merci
madame la ministre la parole est à notre
collègue nathalie de là pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
métropole bordelaise est un pôle
européen majeur du spatial civil et
militaire notamment par la production
des boosters d'ariane la fabrication du
missile m51 dissuasion et l'activité de
microgravité avec les vol zéro-g en 2020
bordeaux sera capitale européenne de
l'espace devenant présidente de la
communauté des villes ariane avec une
première spatiale mondiale le tir
inaugural d'ariane 6 cette présidence
intervient toutefois dans un contexte
international incertain avec l'émergence
d'acteurs industriels très concurrentiel
voilà quelques semaines
ariane groupe annoncé la suppression de
2300 postes dont une grande partie sont
établis dans la métropole bordelaise
on peut y voir une volonté d'adaptation
au contexte
mais on peut surtout comprendre que
l'entreprise peine dans un environnement
agressif
le rapport que vous devez remettre
président de la république sur la
stratégie spatiale militaire comprendra
j'imagine un volet industriel
nous espérons qu'il intégrera pleinement
l'avenir du cluster aquitain parmi les
appuis que l'état peut apporter au
groupe figurent la commande publique
force est de constater que la préférence
européenne n'est pas systématique malgré
l'enjeu
ainsi le satellite de renseignement cso
vient d'être lancé par une fusée soyouz
difficile d'expliquer à nos concitoyens
que nos satellites de renseignement sont
confiés à des fusées russes
la politique de concurrence européennes
érigé en dogme a fait payer un bien cher
tribut à nos entreprises les américains
ne posent pas autant de questions ils
conçoivent américain produit liste
américain et lens américain alors madame
la ministre
quelles perspectives souhaitez-vous
donner à ariane groupe en dehors de
décrocher la lune
quel carnet de commandes quel nombre de
lancements pour la future fusée ariane 6
mais aussi pour le lanceur vega
alternative au lanceur soyouz en cette
année d'élections européennes la france
doit faire campagne pour un bail
européen ait une mesure qui figurait
d'ailleurs dans le programme du candidat
macron je vous en conjure fait le madame
la ministre avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard
merci pour vos rapports de l'homme ces
demandes sont d'ailleurs de la rochère
les innovations madame vidal vous avez
la parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de là vous l'avez rappelé la
france est une grande nation spatiale et
c'est une nation qui est motrice pour le
développement de l'europe du spatial et
si l'europe du spatial a connu autant de
succès c'est parce que l'europe a
toujours soutenu le développement de ces
lanceurs ariane 5 et vega et ariane 6 et
aegas et pour le futur
et ceci bien sûr continuera et ce succès
européen est due à l'excellence et au
professionnalisme du cnes d'ariane
groupe d'arianespace et bien sûr de l'
agence spatiale européenne
mais vous l'avez rappelé aussi nous
sommes dans un contexte qui fait que
d'autres acteurs du spatial on pense
évidemment aspect 6 mais d'autres
acteurs qui se développe aussi en asie
viennent bouleverser le marché
c'est pourquoi nous devons avoir une
politique volontariste de soutien aux
lanceurs et de soutien à la recherche et
au développement qui va nous permettre
d'avoir une ariane 6 plus compétitive et
surtout de prévoir les développements
nécessaires pour carrier m6 puisse
évoluer en fonction du marché nous
investir aussi dans ce que l'on appelle
le new space et les nouveaux usages du
spatial et c'est pourquoi dans le budget
2010 9 200 millions d'euros
supplémentaires ont été prévus pour le
cnes et pour soutenir cela mais il nous
faut aussi aider ariane groupe et arrêté
face à se réorganiser de façon à gagner
en compétitivité c'est ce qu'ils font
eux leur partenaire l'ensemble de leurs
sous traitants et je crois que c'est
très important de rappeler la confiance
que nous avons dans lé lanceur européen
la commissaire européenne a d'ailleurs
signé avec ariane 6 les premiers
contrats pour le lancement des
satellites européens
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
notre collègue jacqueline eustache
brinio pour le groupe l'est républicain
j'avais la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues à skis
si on s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre nous assistons depuis deux
semaines au grand show médiatique du
président de la république le premier en
normandie le second en occitanie six à
sept heures de débats bien orchestrée
bien mises en scène
bref un président en campagne et
probablement plus en campagne qu'elle
écoute des problèmes fondamentaux des
français dans la ligne droite de cette
mise en scène nous apprenions hier que
la secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes coanimera
l'émission ballos mon poste de cyril
hanouna pourrais je reprends ses propos
ramener des gens vers le débat public
les français ne seraient ils pas les
français ne serait-il pas assez subtil
ou assez intelligent pour avoir besoin
de ce type d'émission pour réfléchir
pour comprendre et proposer monsieur le
premier ministre
elles savent être accord que madame
schiappa participent à ce talk show pour
le moins surprenant
[Applaudissements]
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je vous remercie
pour votre question tout en veillant
c'est tout en nuance je vais essayer de
vous répondre sur le même ton
pardon mon étonnement mais je trouve
assez surprenante l'espèce de mise en
abyme dans laquelle vous nous plonger
parce que vous déplorez que l'on parle à
cyril hanouna et vous même vous
consacrer votre temps de parole au sénat
a parlé de cyril hanouna
ça me semble assez surprenant vous
auriez pu parler de sujets dits sérieux
comme par exemple la semaine
[Musique]
il aimait fait dans la modération pour
une fois 1
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui regardent
toutes les semaines l'émission de cyril
hanouna est ce que ces centaines de
milliers de personnes sont des citoyens
comme vous et moi
comme les gens qui écoutent france
culture comme les gens qui regardent
arte le grand débat national voulu par
le président de la république est
organisée par le gouvernement sous la
surveillance des garants sous l'autorité
du premier ministre pour l'organisation
ce débat est d'ailleurs très bien
organisé par mes collègues
emmanuelle wargon et sébastien lecornu
dont je veux l'a salué la mobilisation
exceptionnelle en un temps record et
bien ce grand débat national
il vise à parler à tous les citoyens il
n'y a pas de citoyens de seconde zone
madame la sénatrice le mépris de classe
le mépris de classe d'une intelligence
ya et d'une forme d'élites politiques
qui voudrait s'arroger la seule
responsabilité politique et la seule
capacité à accéder au débat politique et
au débat public
c'est ce mépris de classe qui a nourrit
en partie le mouvement des gilets jaunes
scheer qui en veut non seulement
gouvernement mais à l'ensemble de la
classe politique
je crois qu'on ne répondent pas à des
problèmes politiques de 2019 avec des
solutions de 1999
ne vous en déplaise
adam eustache brinio
alors madame la ministre bien entendu
vos explications mais depuis quelques
temps chaque jour l'image des hommes et
des femmes politiques est dévalorisé ne
soyons donc pas surpris qu avec ce type
de mélange des genres les français
soient de plus en plus critique à
l'égard de leurs élus
vous participez ainsi à l'éloignement et
au rejet de la classe politique dans son
ensemble la politique vaut mieux que
cela
la politique ce n'est pas la télé
réalité l'exemplarité des élus
contribuer à leur respect notre rôle est
de tracer un chemin de créer l'envi et
de l'espoir avec passion à chaque
citoyen et en particulier aux jeunes
générations qui seront les adultes de
demain ramener le débat public à une
émission spectacle ne peut que
poursuivre le travail de dévalorisation
de la politique et ainsi vous y
contribuer mais peut être est ce voulu
alors comment aurions nous pu imaginer
un jour mais c'est vrai c'était un autre
temps
françoise giroud co animer une émission
avec guy lux soit avec léon zitrone
la parole
[Musique]
elle t'a notre collègue
jean yves roux
à qui je redis ma solidarité
l'apparent les cta jean yves roux et je
lui redis ma solidarité
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il ya
maintenant un an et demi le gouvernement
posée comme objectif que la totalité des
services publics seraient dématérialisée
en 2022
l'objectif de dématérialisation un terme
barbare qui signifie que toutes les
procédures administratives devront
s'effectuer en ligne peut être
enthousiasmant mais force est de
constater qu'ils ne sommes à ce jour ni
réaliste ni souhaitable d'envisager sa
généralisation uniforme d'ici trois ans
la démilitarisation inquiète d'autant
qu'elle est perçue comme un cheval de
troie de la réduction des services
publics dans des territoires ruraux et à
terme une centralisation renforcé de
service or nos concitoyens puisque
jamais ont besoin de services publics de
proximité identifiable feasible que main
simple et humain le défenseur des droits
visant ce titre de publier un rapport
qui alerte contre le risque que cette
dématérialisation créer de nouvelles
inégalités d'accès aux services publics
cette inégalité tout d'abord
territoriale de nombreuses communes
n'ont pas accès du tout à internet
territoriale puisque les points d'accès
libre et confidentielle interne elles ne
sont pas disponibles partout et à des
distances variables
cette inégalité est également économique
des artisans locaux ne peuvent déjà pas
accéder à des marchés publics
entièrement des versions dématérialisées
depuis le 1er octobre 2018 pour des
seuils supérieurs à 25 mille euros le
télétravail est quant à lui presque
impossible cette inégalité est aussi
financière car acheter une tablette
smartphone prévoir un abonnement coûte
très cher pour des petits revenus
cette inégalité est enfin culturel selon
le credoc 36% des français ne sont pas
familiarisés au numérique et ce chiffre
est sans doute sous-estimé
or un progrès ne vaut que s'il est
partagé par tous nous élus de la
république bataillon quotidien pour
réduire des fractures territoriales et
sociales ancrée mais aussi les prévenir
aujourd'hui nous avons encore la
possibilité d'agir monsieur le ministre
qu'entendez vous faire pour ne pas
pénaliser celles et ceux qui ne peuvent
accéder à ces nouveaux services publics
comment comptez vous proposer un
accompagnement de grande envergure pour
le concitoyen et comment comptez-vous
consolider les cas l'idée l'égalité
d'accès à nos services publics et ce
dans tous les territoires
je vous remercie la parole est pour vous
répondre et à au ministre de l'action
des comptes publics monsieur gérald
darmanin j'avais la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur satoru
permettez moi tout d'abord de com le
présent du sénat l'a fait de donner
toute la solidarité évidemment du
gouvernement suite à la coordination de
votre permanence et à travers vous
evènement tous les élus quels que soient
leur famille politique qui voit la
permanence c'est à dire des coins de
démocratie vandalisés
monsieur le sénateur vous poser une
question que le sénat connaît bien celle
bien sûr de la nécessaire je lui ai
entendu comme ça dans votre bouche
avancé modernisation de l'administration
française et ça passe notamment par le
défi de la dématérialisation qui rendent
un grand service à nos concitoyens aux
élus locaux et en même temps le fait
qu'ils gagnent france parfois à deux
vitesses celle qui ne connaît pas
l'accès au numérique ou d'ailleurs des
citoyens qui sont atteints de ce qu'on
appelle l'électro nisme c'est la
difficulté c'est pas simplement une
question d'âge la difficulté de remplir
des démarches administratif sur internet
il est certain que le gouvernement s'est
donné comme objectif d'ici 2022 que 100%
des démarches administratives puissent
se faire de manière dématérialisée
mais cet objectif ne veut pas dire
qu'elle remplace ce papier mais c'est
tellement vrai monsieur le sénateur que
lors du débat que j'ai eu l'occasion et
l'honneur de porter dans cette chambre
notamment sur le droit à l'erreur la loi
évoque une de vos collègues madame
gisèle jourda m'a permis de corriger une
des choses que faisait notamment le
ministère c'est à dire la
dématérialisation c'est à dire le
paiement et le remplissage si j'ose dire
des documents administratifs des impôts
simplement en numérique et pour ceux des
territoires qui ne connaissait pas
l'accès au numérique la possibilité bien
sûr pour les français de pouvoir
continuer à remplir le document papier
et à payer en papier en chèques
si j'ose dire c'est pour ça qu'elle
finance de 2016 qui avait été adoptée et
qui avait prévu qu'au dessus de 1000
euros on ne pouvait plus payer notamment
sa taxe foncière autrement que par un
virement bancaire je suis revenu comme
vous l'avez constaté sur cette erreur
qui est effectivement une erreur de
l'administration et la survenue auprès
des administrés pour qu'ils puissent
évidemment continuer à le faire sous un
format papier
alors vous parlez aux comptes à lyon
maintenant vous parler du rapport du
défenseur des droits nous le verrons
évidemment avec beaucoup d'intérêt et ne
quitterons avec vous i la parole est à
notre collègue jean marc boyer pour le
groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez mis le feu au pays en nous
endettant sur une mesure dont personne
ne voulait une mesure près judiciaire
pour le quotidien des territoires sans
pour autant avoir une efficacité
reconnue
je veux parler de 80 kilomètres heure
après six mois d'application
rien ne permet toujours d'affirmer que
la limitation à 80 a réduit le nombre de
tués sur les routes
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
pourtant cette mesure devait être d'une
efficacité immédiate
il n'en est rien le groupe du travail du
sénat sous la haute responsabilité de
michel raison
vous avez fait des proposition
équilibrée acceptable et intelligente
ciblé l'intérieur l'instauration du 80
km heure sur les tronçons accidentogènes
et cela au plus près des territoires par
décision du président du département et
du préfet et conserver le 90 km heure
pour le reste du réseau routier
départemental et surtout ne nous taxer
pas des responsables nous souhaitons
bien sûr que le nombre de morts sur les
routes diminue
nous soutenons toutes les mesures qui
vont dans le sens de l'amélioration de
la sécurité routière de l'état de nos
routes et de nos véhicules et du
comportement des automobilistes
après vos ancien ministre de la cohésion
des territoires et de l'intérieur le
président de la république lors de son
tour de france propose de revenir sur
cette mesure et je cite trouver une
manière plus intelligente des solutions
plus pragmatique et faire quelque chose
qui soit plus acceptable alors monsieur
le premier ministre
envisagez-vous de reconsidérer votre
décision et trouver une solution
acceptable par tous envisagez vous de
suivre les propositions intelligentes du
sénat pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur laurent du neuf la
parole monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur vous avez souligne
effectivement que la question de la
limitation à 80 km/heure sur le réseau
secondaire serait donc au coeur du début
du grand débat qui
est en cours c'est une question
importante vous le soulignez pour nos
concitoyens tant elle touche déplacement
aux mobilités pour ceux notamment qui
vivent en zone rurale et qui parcourt
les quatre cent mille kilomètres de
notre réseau secondaire ce débat donc il
va s'ouvrir avec cette thématique
importante certes de la mobilité mais
aussi de la lutte contre l'insécurité
routière qui reste une préoccupation
forte est un axe fort de la politique de
ce gouvernement dans ce débat il faudra
avoir trois choses en tête la première
et vous nous interroger sur l'efficacité
de la mesure et convient bien évidemment
d'être prudent mais selon les premiers
chiffres provisoires dont nous disposons
sur ce réseau secondaire entre le 1er
juillet 2018 et le 31 décembre 2018 le
nombre de morts a baissé de 13% par
rapport à l'année 2017
deuxièmement il nous appartient il nous
appartiendra également de bien prendre
en compte les effets induits de cette
mesure
je pense notamment au temps de
déplacement je pense notamment aux
effets sur la consommation de carburant
ou encore sur la cohabitation entre les
voitures particulières et les poils au
nous avons demandé d'ailleurs pour
nourrir ce débat à la délégation
ministérielle à la sécurité routière
routière une étude sur ce point qui sera
bien sûr rendu public
et puis il conviendra également
troisième point de prendre en compte la
question de la responsabilité également
des gestionnaires de voirie car remonter
la vitesse sur un axe si telle devait
être la décision prise en tout ou partie
c'est accepter aussi d'ivoire le cas
échéant l'accent l'accident tabilité
augmenter à nouveau et à cet égard bien
évidemment et je crois que c'est ce que
vous souhaitez la vie des présidents de
conseil départemental sera précieux nous
veillerons avec christophe castaner à ce
que ces analyses soient bien rendu
public lui pour que chacun puisse
exprimer en conscience sur ce sujet
notamment s'il devait être apporté des
aménagements à cette mesure mais je sais
que nous partageons tous le même
objectif
cet objectif c'est de sauver des vies
humaines merci monsieur boyer
je regrette monsieur le premier ministre
vous n'ayez pas répondu à ma question
car c'est une mesure que vous avez
imposées
nous ne vous demandons pas de reculer et
de vous renier nous vous demandons de
vous adapter à la réalité nos
territoires et de donner un signe
d'apaisement et à la colère monsieur le
premier ministre
écouter le sénat écoutez la voix de la
ruralité et des territoires
si vous aviez écouté le sénat sur
d'autres sujets tels que l'eau
l'assainissement l'augmentation des
taxes la fête agricole la csg nous n'en
serions pas là
faucon que nous sénateurs nous en
appelons à la raison
merci collègue madame laurence rossignol
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole aujourd'hui le
conseil constitutionnel examine une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui vise à faire
abroger la loi 2016 sur le système
constitutionnel et particulièrement la
pénalisation du client
ce recours est fondé sur deux arguments
la liberté d'entreprendre et le droit à
la vie privée
il faut avoir en tête que 80% des
personnes victimes de traite des êtres
humains
ce leçon à fins d'exploitation sexuelle
et 80% des prostituées de rue sont
étrangères ces deux chiffres
lorsqu on les rapproche suffisent à
casser le mythe romanesque de la
prostituée au grand coeur libre et
heureuse aujourd'hui l'habit le business
du sexe est un des principaux marchés
mafieux et il n'y a pas de prostitution
pas de proxénètes sans client la loi de
2016 considère que tant que l'on pourra
louer acheter ou vendre le corps des
autres l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes sera une illusion
je rappelle que 90% des prostituées sont
des femmes et que par ailleurs la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sera
vaine la seule liberté entreprendre qui
est en cause c'est celle des proxénètes
et des réseaux le seul droit à la vie
privée qui est en cause c'est celui des
clients
la prostitution étant un droit permanent
à l'effraction dans le corps de l'autre
puisque par définition il n'ya pas d'un
team pour les prostituées
un récent sondage nous apprend que près
des trois quarts des français sont
favorables à loix 2016 et pense que on
ne peut pas acheter le corps d autre que
la prostitution est une violence et que
c'est toi doit être confirmé aujourd'hui
le conseil conçu à l'examinent cette
question préjudicielle pas prioritaire
de constitutionnalité madame la ministre
vous avez été très silencieuse sur ce
sujet nous avons été nombreux à nous
exprimer quasiment toutes vos
prédécesseurs l'ont fait en faveur de la
loi
pouvez-vous partager avec nous le
soutien que le gouvernement apportera
par la voie du secrétariat général du
gouvernement
à l'audience au conseil constitutionnel
et nous dire quels arguments ont été
utilisés merci réponse en charge de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la lutte contre les discriminations
des blagues d'istres merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice laurence
rossignol
je connais votre engagement sur ce sujet
et je le salue je voudrais vous signaler
que nous attendons comme vous l'avez
rappelé la décision du conseil
constitutionnel mais je voudrais vous
rassurer le gouvernement a fermement
défendu lors de ses auditions sur mandat
du premier ministre edouard philippe la
constitutionnalité de cette loi et le
gouvernement s'engagent contre le
système prostitutionnel
vous avez raison nous ne faisons pas
forcément via des déclarations ou des
discours au sein du territoire national
mais c'est un axe majeur de la
diplomatie féministes qui est menée par
la france notamment dans le cas de la
présidence française du g7
cette année après le canada et avant les
etats-unis et c'était l'objet de mes
déplacements de cette semaine concernant
la fils je voudrais rappeler que nous
avons appris et décrit en novembre 2010
est pour mettre en oeuvre dans la
continuité de l'action du précédent
quinquennat
toutes les dispositions et rappelait
aussi je l'avais déjà dit ici que j'ai
doublé la subvention de l'association du
mouvement du nid
qui soutient les personnes prostituées
elle est donc passé de 150000 euros à
300000 euros par an et enlever le jour
ce sont 95 mille euros qui ont été
débloqués
c'est à dire que 100 % des demandes
locales ont reçu une réponse positive
en outre je voudrais partager avec vous
une proposition du président de la
république dans le cadre de la
présidence française du g7 dont
l'égalité femmes-hommes sera une grande
priorité
il a proposé à monsieur grégoire théry
que vous connaissez du mouvement du nid
et directeur exécutif de la coalition
pour l'abolition de la prostitution de
rejoindre le conseil consultatif pour
l'égalité femmes hommes dans le cadre du
g7 ce sera une manière aussi pour lui et
pour la france de continuer à porter
cette position qui a de longue date
était la position de la france et qu'il
est toujours merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean louis masson pour les sénateurs de
figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mes chers collègues messieurs
ministre
le soutien populaire au gilet jaune
confirme que les français veulent une
démocratie plus directe
c'est l'objet du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne au contraire les tenants de la
pensée unique et monopolise la presse et
nos institutions
n'écoute le peuple que si celui ci est
de leur avis ainsi en 2008 le parlement
a ratifié sans état d'âme le traité de
lisbonne
en désavouant le résultat du référendum
qui venait d'avoir lieu
voilà bien la preuve que la démocratie
représentative a ses limites
elle fonctionne comme un miroir
déformant en raison notamment des
tripatouillages des partis dominants
par exemple lors des élections de 2012
le front national et le front de gauche
ont obtenu respectivement 18 et 9 % des
suffrages mais n'ont eu chacun que deux
sièges de députés par contre les verts
avec seulement 2% des suffrages ont
obtenu 17 députés
c'est cela la démocratie représentative
les gilets jaunes ont donc bien raison
de réclamer une vraie démocratie et de
se sentir méprisés
par la classe dirigeante d'ailleurs le
soi disant grands débats organisés
actuellement s'inscrit dans la même
logique le président de la république
veut bien discuter mais à condition
d'écarter les sujets tous les sujets
stratégiques où le peuple à clé est
clairement en opposition avec la pensée
dominante
sur tous ces sujets il faut au contraire
que le peuple puisse exprimer
directement
c'est pourquoi le président de la
république devrait avoir le courage de
consulter le peuple par référendum sur
des sujets tels que le matraquage fiscal
et financier contre les retraités ou
l'immigration ou encore le choix entre
soit une europe des nations respectant
la souveraineté des états membres soit
une europe fédéraliste faut qu'en france
je termine le président en france comme
dans beaucoup d'autres pays européens
le peuple est en train de se révolter
contre l'arrogance et le mépris des
dirigeants
monsieur le premier ministre êtes vous
conscient que vous êtes en train de
couper la france en deux entre d'un côté
les pseudos élites bouffis de toutes
fonctions et de l'autre le vrai peuple
qui n'en peut plus
la parole est au ministre auprès du
premier ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement monsieur fenech vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur sénateur masson je
remercie d'autres questions qui me
permettent de dire que pour moi et pour
nous et le gouvernement le peuple les
représentants du peuple et des
territoires ils sont ici et ils sont à
l'assemblée nationale
et qu'il ait jamais une bonne manière de
faire que d'opposer le peuple et ses
représentants et d'opposer la démocratie
représentative et la démocratie
participative
on peut très bien nourrir un débat entre
les citoyens
être à l'écouté et je crois que c'est ce
qu'ils réclament c'est ce qu'ils ont
réclamé en particulier dans le mouvement
qui est né ces derniers jours mais ce
n'est pas le premier épisode où les
citoyens réclament qu'on les écoute plus
et en même temps qui est une traduction
législative et c'est le cas de ce qui se
fait à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
et il me semble par ailleurs vous dites
que nous ne voulons pas écouté le débat
est suffisamment ouvert il ya quatre
grandes thématiques qui ont été ouverts
mais pour ceux qui ont pu assister
d'un point de vue télévisuel ou d'un
point de vue physique aux premiers
échanges de débat avec le président de
la république ou avec des citoyens
simplement on l'a bien vu que la parole
est libre il n'y a pas de sujet tabou et
qu'il nous appartiendra le gouvernement
et qu'il appartiendra aux assemblées de
se saisir de ce que diront les citoyens
pour faire en sorte que nous soyons au
rendez vous de ce que diront les
citoyens est au rendez vous de la
traduction législative qu'il faut avoir
faut jamais opposé monsieur masson le
peuple avec ses représentants parce que
quand on oppose le peuple à eau avec ses
représentants on sait ce que ça donne
l'histoire en est truffé d'exemples dans
ce domaine merci merci les prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu jeudi
31 janvier
je vais suspendre la séance et le sa
reprise à 17h50 pour les explications de
vote et le vote sur la proposition de
loi tendant à améliorer le régime
électoral des instances représentatives
des français établis hors de france
la séance est suspendue merci
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement qui ont été
marqués par un échange très tendu entre
marlier n'échappe à la secrétaire d'état
à l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et jacqueline eustache brinio
sénatrice l'est républicain la sénatrice
leur reprocher de vouloir animer une
émission spéciale dans le cadre du grand
débat national une émission spéciale
avec cyril hanouna sur la chaîne
ces huit pour la sénatrice la
participation à cette émission spectacle
dévalorise la classe politique alors
marlène schiappa est venu se défendre au
micro avec dans son style naturel de la
combativité sous les huées de la
majorité sénatoriale a expliqué que
l'émission de cyril hanouna a été
regardée par des centaines de milliers
de téléspectateurs et qu'il n'y avait
pas de citoyens de seconde zone
et puis elle a ajouté que cette question
traduisait un mépris de classe qui je
cite avait nourri le mouvement des gilet
jaune alors en réplique la sénatrice
jacqueline eustache brinio lui a posé
une question au reste on imaginer il ya
quarante ans la célèbre ministre des
droits des femmes
françois giroux animer un débat avec guy
lux à l'époque animateur vedette
voilà pour ce temps fort des questions
d'actualité du sénat au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions et première invitée de notre
multiplex
c'est frédéric vidal 1 la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur qui est à vos
côtés at elle traduit
oui oui delphine effectivement je suis
avec frédéric vidal et nous allons faire
ensemble et bien un bilan de la
plateforme parcours sub cela alors que
le défenseur des droits vient d'émettre
des recommandations pour plus de
transparence notamment pour rendre
publics les critères précis à partir
desquels et bien les universités
sélectionne les étudiants à ce que vous
allez bien suivre les recommandations du
défenseur des droits
alors nous avons eu en fait d'une part
un rapport qui a été remis au parlement
sur le fonctionnement de la plateforme
l'avis de la cnil la vie du défenseur
des droits et nous avons d'ores et déjà
tenu compte de ces recommandations
puisque cet outil à vocation à être
évalués pour pouvoir évoluer et
permettre à tous les jeunes de faire
plus en confiance
encore que l'an dernier et bien leur
choix d'orientation et leur choix pour
l'affectation dans l'enseignement
supérieur pour connaître et qu'il faut
plus de parmi les choses par les choses
qui ont été proposées recommandé par le
défenseur des droits et il ya la
connaissance des critères qui permettent
les classements des dossiers et ce sont
des éléments qui ont été ajoutées cette
année à la plate forme par rapport à ce
qui existait l'année dernière il y a
aussi une demande qui a été faite par le
défenseur des droits de travailler à une
meilleure mobilité au sein de
l'ile-de-france est une proposition qui
a été fait aussi par le sénateur la
faune et que nous avons aussi d'ores et
déjà intégrée à la plate forme donc ce
qui est très important c'est que cet
outil soit évaluée en permanence parce
que c'est ce qui garantira qu'il soit
toujours plus performant au service de
la démocratisation de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur ce qui est
l'objectif premier de ce gouvernement
il y avait aussi des demandes répétées
de certains sénateurs pour connaître les
algorithmes locaux alors est-ce qu'il ya
bien des algorithmes locaux et aller
vous allez faire connaître madame la
ministre
c'est une question récurrente qui relève
en fait de chaque établissement c'est ce
que j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre et
c'est ce que ce qui a été confirmé
d'ailleurs par par plusieurs expertises
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
chaque année les populations d'étudiants
de futurs étudiants qui veulent
s'inscrire sont différentes et donc ce
qui est important c'est que les critères
d'examen soit connue c'est le cas cette
année
ensuite eh bien les jury délibère et
sept délibérations des jurys il est
difficile de savoir à l'avancé comment
elle va se dérouler tant qu'on ne
connaît pas les candidats
donc je crois que sur ce sujet ce qui
est vraiment important c'est de rappeler
que les filières sélectives continue à
sélectionner au travers de la plateforme
parcours super comme elle le faisait
auparavant et l'objectif pour les
universités c'est bien de connaître leur
public et de faire en sorte qu'il soit
le mieux accueilli possible c'est tout
l'objectif des parcours de hulu ici
c'est tout l'objectif des commissions
d'accompagnement de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur
je crois que cette plateforme a été
améliorée parce que nous avons su
écouter les usagers de cette plateforme
l'année dernière les tentes délais vont
être raccourcie de très nombreuses
choses qui doivent permettre à chacun de
faire le plus sereinement possible dans
les semaines qui viennent leurs voeux
merci beaucoup frédéric vidal d'inverser
a vendu à mes questions et également je
veux non loin de vous ne vont avoir
emmanuelle wargon pour pouvoir parler et
bien de ce fameux grand débat qui a été
lancé bonjour notamment bien sûr avec
les performances un d'emmanuel macron
c'est ainsi qu'on a parlé notamment dans
l'eure ou encore dans le lot
et justement il ya un troisième
déplacement ce jeudi d' emmanuel macron
à ce que cela va ressembler à ce que
l'on a vu la semaine dernière ce que
vous pouvez nous donner des détails sur
ce déplacement des manuellement alors je
suis désolé je ne vais pas pouvoir vous
donner de détails précis sur le prochain
déplacement mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que le président souhaite
varier un peu les formats pour avoir la
possibilité de rencontrer
voilà différents types de population les
maires mais pas que et voilà il le
risque que qui est souvent pointé du
doigt notamment avec ce début de grandes
des buy ins et de troupes personnifié ce
grand débat dès que la figure des
manuels macro est ce que ce n'est pas un
risque alors même que et bien beaucoup
jugent que le grand débat a été
trop fargo cité par le gouvernement
écoutez le grand débat c'est aujourd'hui
750 réunion qui sont publiés sur la
plateforme grand débat point fr ce sont
plus de 500 mille personnes qui sont
venues se renseigner ce sont déjà plus
de 15000 contributions individuelles qui
ont été postées alors que la possibilité
de contribuer individuellement a été
ouverte ce matin donc je crois qu'au
contraire on voit une belle mobilisation
des français qui ont envie de débattre
et c'est ce que nous disent les maires
les associations les citoyens qu'on voit
donc c'est une belle dynamique donc
beaucoup d'optimisme pour le début de ce
grand débat emmanuelle wargon beaucoup
de confiance dans l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens et la volonté d'être à la
hauteur de cette confiance pour pouvoir
renouer les fils du dialogue
bien merci beaucoup avait répondu à mes
questions également je vois non loin
d'eux mou et bien marlène schiappa
bonjour bonjour bien vous avez été au
centre des attentions de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notamment avec cet échange avait déjà
que le stage brigneau qui vous a attaqué
sur votre présence vendredi
mais à cette émission de cyril hanouna
balances ton post vous lui avez répondu
que vous cherchez à parler à tous les
français mais ce que vous comprenez tout
de même les réticences de certains et
les attaques
moi ce qui m'étonne qu'on ait des
réticences pourquoi pas comme disait
rosa luxembourg la liberté c'est
toujours la liberté de penser autrement
mais je ne force personne à regarder
l'émission c'est la luna vendredi les
gens qui ont envie de rester sur public
sénat vendredi soir peuvent passer la
soirée de vendredi sur public sénat ya
aucun souci à ce niveau-là
donc qu'on déplore qu'on ne regarde pas
cette émission à titre personnel je le
comprends qu'on m'attaque d'une façon
aussi agressive et aussi vigoureuse et
qu'on me fasse des objectifs groupe est
de cette manière dans l'hémicycle tout
ça parce que je vais m'adresser à des
personnes qui n'ont pas l'honneur de
faire partie de l'intelligentsia où des
gens à qui on s'adresse d'habitude dans
ce type de débat non je ne le comprends
pas vous ne jugez pas qu'il ya un
mélange des genres en allant dans ce
type d'émission est en étant une
personnalité politique août et le 1er de
la porte parole du parti les
républicains madame biousse est déjà
allé dans une émission de cyril hanouna
je n'ai pas entendu qui que ce soit à
râler nicolas dupont aignan a déjà été
invité de cette émission
alexis corbière à dernière quatre ans
mon collègue mounir majidi
et il ne me semble pas que ça ait fait
un tel débat et une telle polémique
donc je crois qu'il n'y a pas de citoyen
de seconde zone les gens qui regardent
cyril hanouna ont le droit de participer
au grand débat national et j'y vais non
pas pour faire le show et m'amuser faire
le clown
j'y vais pour parler du grand débat
national et pour dire à des gens qui
peut-être ne regarde pas public sénat ne
regarde pas lcp ne regarde pas les
émissions politiques
comment ils peuvent s'emparer de ce
grand débat et les ramener vers le débat
public vers la démocratie
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu sur
marlène schiappa match pas qu'il assume
donc parfaitement à 100% sa présence
vendredi dans l'émission de cyril
hanouna
merci beaucoup au tam pour ses réactions
et loïc hervé sénateur centriste de la
savane nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir on va pas de ce grand débat mais
avant cela compense et vous justement de
la présence de la ministre shea a pas
cette émission présentée par cyril
hanouna
or d'une part que des hommes ou des
femmes politiques participent à des ce
type d'émission ne me choque pas en soi
en revanche que dans le cadre du grand
débat national
on utilise ce type d'émission avec une
ministre pour débattre avec les français
mais j'ose beaucoup plus parce que je
pense qu'il faut regarder une forme de
dignité il ya des émissions politiques
qui sont faites pour ça et ces émissions
qui risque d'entraîner le débat dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
à mon avis de ceux qui attendent les
français ne me convient pas et il n'y
avait aucune aucun excédent là dans la
question de notre collègue stage
brigneau la réponse de la ministre a été
de mon point de vue disproportionnée
moi je comprends pas qu'on a avec une
ministre dans au moment où la république
tremble au moment où les gilets jaunes
en ont besoin et exprimons les français
aussi ont besoin de s'exprimer faut
garder le plus grand la plus grande
dignité dans la qualité des débats
on aurait dû faire ça sur public sénat
et justement emmanuel macron reprend la
main en quelque sorte un sur
l'organisation de ce grand débat avec
eux plusieurs déplacements notamment la
semaine dernière ça lui a plutôt profité
on voit qu'il remonte un peu dans les
sondages le chef de l'état ça apaise les
choses donner la parole aux français
cela ne vous il est indéniablement
remonter sur le cheval avec
les deux premiers débats en normandie et
dans le sud ouest c'est un exercice
difficile et risqué pour lui puisque ils
sont des débats qui sont assez longs
dans lequel il a un rôle extrêmement
actif
donc il ya ça et puis aussi tout un tas
de débats qui sont organisées dans les
territoires où là on n'a pas encore une
idée totalement objectif de ce qui va se
passer mais où la place des
parlementaires et d'une vraie question
le rôle des maires parlementaires d'être
un peu et bien contourner complètement
céder complètement dont le parlement
département complètement le aujourd'hui
les parlementaires qui pourraient avoir
un rôle de greffiers du débat voir de
grands témoins parfois pour que les
choses puissent être traduit dans la loi
ensuite n'ont pas de rôle à jouer
on leur a bien fait comprendre on l'a
bien fait comprendre encore aujourd'hui
je le regrette parce que je crois que
les parlementaires peuvent effectivement
avoir un rôle et j'avais fait une
proposition à l'époque du préfet 20
peremans le préfet chargé de
l'organisation du débat dans le
département il le fait avec les
associations d'élus un certain nombre de
maires qui sont prêts à organiser des
choses et et pour ma part j'estime que
les parlementaires ne sont pas assez
associé à ce débat et les proposition
que j'avais faite non pas été retenu
mais peu importe j'avais fait une
proposition il ya quelques mois au
moment où mme la classe des gilets
jaunes était la plus forte que l'on
suspende les travaux parlementaires que
les 925 députés et sénateurs aille sur
le terrain à la rencontre des français
du gilet jaune ou de ceux qui ne portent
pas ce type de 2,2 gillet
parce que je crois que dans la
démocratie représentative
ce sont aux représentants du peuple et
en particulier aux législateurs d'aller
au contact de nos concitoyens un
relâchement de la traduction les ors des
propositions à des doléances alors je
vous rassure
j'attends pas du préfet de département
de de m'associer j'irai moi-même dans
les débats organisés par des mes
collègues élus par les maires au contact
des gens est d'ailleurs dans une optique
d coûte d'avantagé dans une optique
active et et nous aurons évidemment sur
la base de ce qu'ils on va remonter du
terrain à nous faire une idée nous même
pas seulement présent la république nous
faire une idée nous mêmes de ski à
mettre dans la ou les lois qui
déboucheront suite au 15 mars
vous êtes membre de la commission des
lois loïc hervé vous avez assisté hier à
cette audition d'alexandre benalla alors
que nous sommes à la veille 1 de la fin
de travaux de cette commission dont
enquête parlementaire quel bilan en
faites-vous on a vu hier alexandre
benalla se réfugier derrière et bien son
information judiciaire pour ne pas
répondre aux questions des sénateurs
vous avez été frustré parce que vous
avec malgré tout appris de nouveaux
éléments
la frustration est réel car à durban a
refusé de répondre à un stand de
questions se retranchant comme vous le
dites
derrière une
enquête judiciaire qui est en cours
premier élément deuxièmement elle a
confirmé que les passeports qui étaient
restés à l'elysée lui ont été restitués
début octobre ce qui lui permet d'aller
au tchad de voyage et une vingtaine de
fois dans des pays étrangers
est-ce qu'il a posé la première fois le
19 septembre dernier il avait affirmé ne
pas avoir les passeports une en sa
possession il ya de prod2 problème il
n'a pas répondu à des questions de la
commission des lois du sénat qui revêtu
des questions des décors étaient d'une
commission denquête donc en cela la
commission des lois aura statué sur le
fait de savoir si il devait répondre ou
pas deuxièmement sur la question des
passeports cros monde proprement dite at
il menti ou pas là aussi nous devrons en
délibéré entre nous au sein de la
commission des lois du sénat ce qui est
mais encore une fois alexandre benalla
n'est pas le centre de notre intérêt
commission des lois du sénat son travail
c'est de faire en sorte de vérifier que
les institutions du pays en particulier
l'exécutif fonctionne de manière
régulière et que la sécurité du
président de la république que le
fonctionnement même de la présence de la
république soit d un fonctionnement qui
soit conforme à la loi et que ni n'y ait
pas des passe-droits qui sera attribuée
à tel ou tel collaborateur
dysfonctionnements c'est seulement la
dérive personnelle d'un homme
pour moi il ya évidemment alexandrina
qui ne manque pas de toupet c'est
l'expression du j'utilise manière
habituelle
et puis en même temps l'absence totale
de contre-pouvoir de contrôle de
correctifs dès qu' un certain nombre de
choses ont été constatés il aurait dû
être contrôlée à l'intérieur de
l'institution élyséennes et on aurait dû
stopper ces agissements il n'y avait il
a fallu qu'ils commettent des actes du
1er mai pour que la chose soit rendue
publique et que la commission d' enquête
du sénat soit créée après celle de
l'assemblée nationale et qu'on ait pu la
mener jusqu'à son terme
moi ce que je trouve très intéressant
c'est que en six mois on a pu faire un
seconde audition entendre et réentendre
x men à la entendre et j'entends dans un
compte de deux personnes et maintenance
étendue rapport puisque nous ne sommes
pas là pour juger qui que ce soit nous
sommes là pour faire pour tirer des
conclusions de ce qui s'est passé et
faire des préconisations qui s'il le
faut traduire ça dans la loi
hier on le disait il n'a pas et bien
répondu à toutes les questions c'est
malgré tout dans son droit il a refusé
sur les conseils de son avocate de
s'auto incriminer on peut aussi le
comprendre c'est une stratégie de
défense comme une autre oui sauf que
choisit il a choisi sur la question des
passeports dont il dit qu'il ya une
enquête
il a quand même choisi de répondre à un
certain nombre de questions
il a même au début de l'audition fait
une précision en direction de madame
salle vrignaud à nouveau et ce faisant
il se contredit puisque il répond de
lui-même à une question qu'on ne lui
pose pas est qui et qui touchent
directement soit disant l' enquête
judiciaire est en cours
donc c'est un choix qu'il a pris une
stratégie de sa part
je pense que c'est dommage que il n'est
pas dit les choses à la commission des
lois du sénat qui a été très correct à
son égard la première fois à la seconde
fois très correct courtoise le président
était extrêmement fermes sur les
principes sur le cadre du mandat qui est
le nôtre il a rappelé les choses et
philippe bas quelqu'un qui est très à
cheval sur ces questions là un coup de
projecteur sur le sénat aussi sur le
ballon l'action de contrôle
oui paradoxalement au moment où on remet
en question peut-être l'existence même
du bicamérisme du sénat de montrer que
le sénat est une chambre indépendante
qui mène son travail de contrôle de
l'action de l'exécutif du gouvernement
des grandes politiques publiques de
manière totalement libre et d'ailleurs
dans un une forme de consensus
trans partisan qui est qui est essentiel
ce fait honneur au sénat alors je sais
que médiatiquement public sénat en
particulier mais aussi le sénat a été
mis au centre du débat
c'est heureux et moi je m'en réjouis
merci à l'uqar est effectivement vous
avez été 194 unités spectateurs à suivre
cette audition hier en direct sur public
sénat c'est un nouveau record d'audience
pour la chaîne
merci à loïc hervé on se quitte sur ces
images aussi vous allez le voir c'est
assez rare du sénat sous la neige
quelques flocons sont tombés ce matin
sur le jardin du luxembourg
et à paris à cette nuit prudence donc
[Musique]